of all the contaminated buildings on the
centerfield nuclear site
this one is the greatest concern the 60
year old magnoc swarf storage silo is
known as western europe's most hazardous
building
it's aging and leaking unstable nuclear
waste
now finally after 15 years of work
they've engineered a way to get to grips
with it
a remotely operated grabber that can
scoop up the waste below assisted and
maintained by robotic arm the levels of
radiation behind the lead glass are far
too high for humans
we've got a fair idea of what was tipped
into the into the compartments over the
last 40-50 years
but as we go in to retrieve the waste
using the sort of the equivalent of a
fair ground grab
it's a lucky dip arrangement we get what
waste we will get
it's one reason this process will take
years the other is this waste store is
vast so using this remotely operated
camera matt here can show us the nuclear
waste that's about seven meters directly
below where i'm standing and what we can
see there is just what's floating on the
surface of the water beneath that is
another 16 meters or so of intensely
radioactive sludge and there's 22
compartments like this
once removed the waste will come to this
new facility built to house the majority
of sellafield's radioactive waste it's
transported in these shielded drop proof
containers
boxes of waste will come down to the
hatch above me onto a bogey that will
then carry them down this tunnel to two
and eventually eight storage vaults and
we're some of the last people to ever
stand
in this tunnel because once the building
starts receiving nuclear waste no humans
will be able to come down here for more
than a century
the vaults are concrete bunkers each
large enough to hold nearly three and a
half thousand boxes stacked nine high so
how do the people who built it feel
about their hard work being boxed up
never to be seen for generations
we are making the country safer and the
world safer every time we take a step
forward so we do it quietly sometimes we
don't often scream from the hilltops
that we do it
today's workers may be proud but in
economic terms the cold war era mess
left at centerfield is a national
disgrace
cleanup is projected to cost 97 billion
pounds over the next 120 years
the government now wants new nuclear
plants is this an industry we can trust
with our energy future
it's important that sellerfield deal
with these legacies of the past doing
nothing is not an option here this waste
needs to move out of these legacy
facilities however you do make a very
good point it's the capability that uk
has and can demonstrate that capability
of managing not only design operational
facilities but decommissioning
demolition and ultimately licensing
lessons have been learned new nuclear
operators must now pay up front for
future decommissioning but questions
will loom over nuclear power until
there's a safe permanent home for our
radioactive waste tom clark sky news
cumbria